bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
enfin analyser le trailer de Ant-Man 3
quantumania comment vous dire que je
suis trop heureux cela fait plus d'un an
et demi que je vous bassine avec kangle
conquérant que je vous le dise pour
l'avenir du MCU et il est enfin là nous
avons enfin un premier aperçu un premier
visuel une première entrée en matière du
personnage et franchement il est très
réussi donc écoutez ne perdons pas de
temps il y a plein de choses à dire
théorisons et analysons ensemble ce
trailer donc voilà écoutez let's go déjà
il faut rappeler la base de la base
quant au Mania est prévu pour le 17
février 2023 il sera le premier film de
la phase 5 et c'est très important de le
rappeler la phase 4 qui est la première
phase de la saga du multivers a servi à
introduire énormément de personnages de
concepts et tout ce qui s'ensuit mais
désormais avec la phase 5 on va changer
de vitesse on va commencer à rentrer
dans le dur et AMEN les longs enjeux qui
composeront l'histoire de la saga du
multivers donc Ant-Man 3 qui est le
premier film de la fac 5 et qui en plus
nous introduit pour la première fois
véritablement Kang le Conquérant
préparez-vous enfin avoir l'avenir se
dessiner petit à petit et enfin avoir
des réponses quant au futur de Marvel et
justement par rapport à tout ça
tournons-nous vers le trailer qui semble
plutôt explicite concernant l'intrigue
de base du film et qui pourrait
clairement nous apporter nous retrouvons
Scotland dans sa vie de tous les jours
effectivement ce dernier est passé de
détenus à Avengers avec notamment
endgame où il a été la clé permettant de
ramener tout le monde suite aux actes de
Thanos mais là où il y a un premier
point intéressant c'est que bien
évidemment comme je vous en ai déjà
beaucoup parlé le chant quantique et
l'élément qui symbolise les films
Ant-Man et du coup plus nous avançons
dans le temps et l'histoire est plus
Ant-Man et sa team vont développer leur
connaissance et leur maîtrise de cette
dimension sauf que coup de théâtre suite
aux événements de Ant-Man 2 avec
notamment Ghost qui souffrait à cause
d'un accident lié au champ quantique ou
tout simplement Janet van DIN qui est
resté bloqué des années là-bas Ant-Man
et son équipe ce sont rendus compte
qu'ils pouvaient apporter de l'aide aux
gens par le biais de cette dimension et
qu'à si longue la fille de Scott dont
l'actrice a changé va développer un
artefact permettant au possible Jean
perdus dans le champ quantique de
retrouver le chemin de la réalité de la
terre comme un satellite comme elle nous
dit et c'est là qu'un autre point
intéressant surgit car effectivement
Janet van DIN n'a jamais eu l'occasion
de nous raconter ce qu'elle a vécu dans
cette dimension je vous le rappelle
quand même mais cette dernière a passé
plus de 30 ans là-bas donc elle connaît
très bien les lieux et surtout quand on
relativise d'après le trailer Janet
semble en savoir beaucoup plus que prévu
concernant cette dimension et alors
qu'une ville entière fait partie du
champ quantique l'année dernière n'était
pas là-bas quand ils sont venus la
chercher donc peut-être qu'elle fuyait
quelque chose ou plutôt quelqu'un et
cela nous permet de rebondir sur un
autre point puisqu''étant donné que tout
le monde sera absorbé dans le champ
quantique Ant-Man et les autres se
retrouveront séparés Ant-Man va se
retrouver à marchander et travailler
avec Kang alors que c'est quelqu'un de
très dangereux et Janet qui n'est pas
avec lui ne pourra pas lui avertir que
ce dernier serait une menace de ce que
je comprends logiquement par rapport au
trailer c'est que Janet van dyn
servirait de point de repère au
spectateur qui ne connaîtraient pas très
bien le chant quantique et ce qui le
composent comme montrer elle serait
celle qui va nous expliquer et nous
introduire les nouveaux concepts du film
et tiens justement le chant quantique et
notamment kangle conquérant il va
falloir en parler car il y a clairement
beaucoup de choses à dire et notamment
des théories à faire premièrement
quelque chose que je vous disais à
l'époque den Game c'est que la
découverte que le chant quantique permet
de voyager dans est un élément
incroyable qui va forcément intéresser
Kang le Conquérant Tony Stark a pu
appréhender la chose et grâce à son
génie il a découvert le moyen de
pleinement l'utiliser pour traverser les
époques et tout ça c'est un truc que
Kang qu'on voit pour celles et ceux qui
ne sont pas bien familiers avec le
personnage Kang et comme son nom
l'indique un conquérant et ce qui le
symbolise clairement c'est le voyage
dans le temps du coup vous assemblez ces
deux thématiques et vous obtenez Kang
est un conquérant qui veut conquérir les
époques et les temporalités et c'est ce
qu'il fait notamment principalement dans
les comics du coup adapté au MCU et au
film ant Man 3 Kang se voit obliger de
se servir du champ quantique pour
voyager à travers le temps et conquérir
les époques comme les Avengers ont
réussi à faire dans endgame cependant
c'est quelque chose qui nous permet de
nous poser d'autres questions pourquoi
Kang n'agit que maintenant pourquoi ce
dernier a Jésus ant Man 3 pour
intervenir et bien il semblerait que le
trailer nous utilise un petit peu la
réponse à cette question vu que le film
va nous montrer la rencontre entre
Scotland et Kang ainsi que la naissance
d'un marché entre les deux personnages
c'est que quelque chose chez Ant-Man
intéresse Kang le Conquérant il se
pourrait et ce n'est qu'une supposition
je vais aller un peu loin mais que Kang
souhaiterait se servir dantman pour qu'à
terme ce dernier découvre enfin le
chemin vers la temporalité de notre
héros bon je vais un peu loin comme je
vous ai dit pour le moment mais ce qui
me fait penser ceci c'est que dans les
comics Kang est énormément intéressé par
l'époque et l'ère des Avengers qu'il
considère comme une époque prospère pour
bâtir un empire contrairement à son
futur lointain ou l'humanité c'est
totalement dégradée mais voilà je
divague un petit peu pour rentrer un
petit peu plus dans les détails du
trailer je vous avoue que j'ai repéré
certains éléments qui je pense méritent
très clairement d'être souligné en fait
tout d'abord il faut souligner quand
même trois est un film qui va servir
d'introduction à Kang le Conquérant
c'est la première fois que nous allons
voir le personnage à l'écran et il faut
le justifier pour les nouvelles
personnes qui ne sont pas adeptes de
l'univers Marvel du coup cela veut dire
qu'il va falloir introduire le
personnage que ce soit son histoire son
caractère ses pouvoirs et notamment les
références par rapport au comics et je
pense que je suis légitime pour
effectuer cette tâche je vous invite
bien évidemment à voir ma vidéo complète
dédiée à Kang le Conquérant pour celles
et ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas bien le
personnage et cela vous permettra de
comprendre pourquoi ce dernier est si
unique le premier détail que j'aimerais
souligner ce sont les protagonistes qui
vont à la rencontre de Scotland et de
cassis dans les comics il faut savoir
que le micro vert ce qui est en gros le
monde du champ quantique et bien c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas vraiment
développé par exemple nous savons qu'il
y a de la vie dans le microverse
notamment des drôles de créatures mais
voilà cela s'arrête là ce n'est pas
vraiment développé cependant pour le MCU
vu qu'ils aiment fusionner les éléments
des comics et notamment bah du coup avec
la présence de Kang dans cette dimension
et bien je soupçonne que ces personnages
sont les potentiels soldats du vilain
pourquoi cela en fait dans l'histoire de
Kang des comics quand ce dernier va
malencontreusement atterrir au 41e
siècle il va nous décrire cette époque
comme une aire de désolation où
l'humanité s'effondrée et que les
humains sont désormais des barbares et
c'est là-bas qu'il va devenir Kang le
conquérant et unifier les restes de
l'humanité derrière lui sauf que les
comics qui traitent cette histoire date
des années 60 donc il y avait une vision
un peu nulle du futur donc on retrouve
des humains et des gens avec des armures
un petit peu bizarres très différents
les uns les autres et un petit peu en
mode Anarchie et c'est là que c'est très
intéressant car une fois que Kang aura
unifié ces gens-là derrière lui il va en
son armée et ces derniers vont le suivre
dans ces conquêtes à travers ces voyages
dans le temps etc par rapport au trailer
je trouve personnellement que l'on
retrouve ce délire ces entités possèdent
tous des armures qui rappellent un peu
celle des gens du 41e siècle et sont
tous très différents et puis en plus ils
ont tous des armes ce qui rappelle ce
côté
mercenaire/solda et puis on n'oublie pas
que cela concorde avec l'idée qu'il
trouve Scott et Cassis et puis qu'il
l'amène à leur chef qui va marchander
avec lui bref ensuite il y a également
le fait que nous sommes dans une immense
ville siégeant dans le champ quantique
bon cela fait partie des théories phares
dont on a parlé ces dernières années
mais il semblerait bien que nous ayons
des réponses sur la fameuse ville cachée
d'entman 2 et vu que la ville et le film
sont liés à Kang je pense que nous
pouvons assez aisément confirmé qu'il
s'agisse de chronopolis une ville
entièrement technologique qui est le
quartier général du conquérant et où il
planifie ses prochaines conquêtes enfin
il faut que nous parlions du code
couleur et c'est probablement l'élément
le plus intrigant notamment concernant
les théories les pouvoirs de Kang nous
sont présentés avec la couleur bleue
étant l'un des plus grands scientifiques
de son air Kang est un expert du voyage
dans le temps de la technologie ainsi
que de la robotique Kang et quelqu'un
qui fabrique beaucoup de robots ou
autres bottes rappelez-vous des Gardiens
du Temps de Loki qui n'étaient que des
robots et bien là c'est pareil avec son
armée il semblerait que nous soyons face
à une armée de robots à son effigie
ainsi qu'autre armement etc et tout est
lié à la couleur bleue empreinte qui
rappelle que c'est quelque chose lui
obéissant et fait de la main de Kang
mais du coup cela m'interroge désormais
sur plein de choses concernant le MCU
car nous savons que Kang est censé
devenir central dans le futur de Marvel
et est censé devenir une future grande
menace du coup est-ce qu'il n'existerait
pas déjà certains artefacts ou autres
éléments qui ont le même code couleur et
qui du coup pourrait être lié à Kang en
vrai il y a matière à débattre mais
voilà c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour en
parler aujourd'hui enfin je pense que
nous pouvons conclure sur le physique du
vilain deux trucs m'ont interpellé dans
le trailer concernant Kang le premier
élément son les cicatrices sur son
visage en fait dans la tunique classique
de kangle conquérant c'est très ne sont
pas des cicatrices mais des éléments de
son casque et pour le MCU ils ont fait
le choix que ces deux traits soient en
fait des cicatrices se présente sur le
visage du personnage et c'est très
intéressant car je pense que c'est pour
que les fans ne confondent pas celui qui
demeure dans Loki et cet autre identité
qui est Kang le conquérant mais du coup
cela nous fait aller plus loin car ce
serait une confirmation que ce n'est pas
le même personnage dans le sens où celui
qui demeure n'est pas le Kang en gros
d'anthman 3 est-ce que vous voyez ce que
je veux dire après nous aurons les
réponses dans le film mais typiquement
celui qui demeure nous ne savons pas de
l'univers il provient là avec Ant-Man
III si nous suivons la logique du chant
quantique et des règles du MCU il
s'agirait possiblement du Kang de notre
réalité pour rappel Kang est un
protagoniste né au 31e siècle donc le
troisième millénaire au vu du film qui
nous attend je pense que nous allons
faire face à un jeune Kang le Conquérant
dans le sens où il n'a pas forcément
encore bien conscience du multivers il
s'est simplement servi du champ
quantique pour quitter le 31e siècle
voyager puis installé son QG dans le
champ quantique et puis l'autre élément
qui m'a interpellé du coup c'est la cape
du personnage car en fait dans les
comics il existe un Kang le conquérant
qui possède une cape et cette cape est
un élément visuel qui permet de
distinguer ce Kang parmi les autres en
mode c'est le camp principal celui que
nous devons suivre celui dont l'histoire
est différente et du coup je me demande
s'ils vont réitérer la chose avec langue
ou non mais bon tout ça c'est du détail
écoutez je pense que nous allons nous
arrêter là concernant ce premier trailer
il va y avoir matière à faire de belles
théories mais sincèrement chaque chose
en son temps ce sera l'objet de futurs
belles vidéos quant au Mania est
clairement le film que j'attends le plus
depuis Doctor Strange 2 et je peux vous
assurer que normalement il va chambouler
le MCU comptez sur moi pour vous
accompagner et continuer à vous
expliquer l'univers Marvel en attendant
si la vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
laisser un petit pouce bleu un petit
commentaire sur l'arrivée de Kang enfin
il est là et surtout à vous abonner pour
ne pas louper les prochaines vidéos sur
ce les amis c'était Argo rock vive
kangle conquérant que le line art saut
avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]